qu'est ce que vous voulez je le
commissaire maigret est alors on a droit
de chez soi non je dois avoir un
entretien avec vous si possible bush et
tortueux alors il doit être les
déjeuners
je vous suis voulez vous asseoir merci
je préfère rester debout
vous avez vu votre père vous voulez dire
depuis je suis rentré non qui vous a dit
ferdinand
il voulait me faire parler mais je ne
pouvais pas alors j'ai couru dans ma
chambre je me suis enfermé coiffeur me
regarder dans la glace puisque vous
voulez tout savoir je cherche à
découvrir à qui je ressemblais à papa ou
maman est acquis ressembler le monde à
ma mère
la détester c'est pas vrai je l'aimais
mais des plus d'une fois là croyez vous
coupable
j'ai jamais dit ça tout à l'heure je
vous ai entendu vous disputer violemment
toutes les deux ça n'a rien à voir avec
le crime
mademoiselle vague vous l'aimiez non
c'était une petite intrigante qui
faisait croire à mon père qu'elle
l'aimait elle n'a fait que l'isoler un
peu plus debout de la famille sans zèle
l'atmosphère aurait été moins lourde
j'ai dû souvent intervenir pour calmer
les fureurs de ma mère c'est pas facile
de lui faire entendre raison
c'est pourtant ce que je vais essayer de
faire